hello and welcome to this video
sauerkraut yeah let's play solid chance
against him and what do I do now b6
maybe b6 just kind of doing what he does
ok hmm don't quite know where to put my
pieces maybe root c8c takes Knight eggs
and give for that is worrying me a
little bit if I play Queen to may be
here and I'm like winter so ok seems
that she tries to play with Queen a1
this kind of thing
hmm
ya can't do that man nothing much that I
can do that no tea for ok hmm I would
love to play deform and d4 takes 95 494
but i wonder if i can do it it takes if
i hears g7 detect this is the problem
how come on i still do it it's just too
attractive night f4 ok so I've got cream
g4 as a possible move probably that
whole thing is not working and okay if I
go Queen g4 yeah come on let's do that
ask questions later probably not going
to work
I think you can just take stuff okay
this is also a move I can take the three
though that's interesting look chicks
also possible I'll take with the night
down oh wow that wasn't on my agenda at
all Knight f6
o Knight f6 Wow
okay that's not actually a threat Bishop
takes I wouldn't win all kinds of
material check it-- will be one I don't
win the whole rock I don't win the whole
rook unfortunately as Bishop d3 years on
but I have night no don't have 95
I'd still not enough am I shoot I
thought I win the whole look then I
don't yeah it's not enough unfortunately
I felt I had something there something
cool did you just know he just took
everything ahead and it's fine ah what a
shame okay
even c6 as possible
ah what a shame
mmm time warning
I a squint xe5 ok now it's got twin 65
or that one or that one
and this it looks funny right everything
is attacked somehow i can take about
every move wins i think i offer
everything eggs both rooks yeah
unfortunately yeah i can resign him
black resign yeah i just i just totally
miscalculated here i I thought I you
just told me that comes to another
zealand yeah i was a funny funny thing
we five okay well it was quite
interesting and here came i can't take
on c5 but this is Queen g6 now is given
given by the comp of course giving equal
just 0000 yeah that doesn't work I what
I did not see is that I'm not winning
the whole look there I thought I win the
whole look and that would be to pieces
and and rook and I don't get it because
him he's attacking this antibiotic here
here and yeah this is also not enough so
I miscalculated he I'm just yeah I'm
just fishing but I'm losing yeah I am so
what is the engine giving hear this and
equal okay
okay so it should cheeks look chicks I'm
threatening here so this makes quite
some sense and then be takes is given as
as the line yet that this could be equal
I can I definitely understand yeah it's
a I mean very very tough position but I
don't really feel like I'm were so
anything I am white also I mean so he's
got active pieces this is this pressure
is quite nice tough game but I just
didn't see the the combination there
correctly okay thanks for watching